A few decades earlier
the 20 common questions were a bit
different. Now it is different. Before
9/11,
before 11th of September 2001, before
the twin tower attack in New York, the
top of the charts was why does Islam
permit a man to have more than one wife?
Now after 9/11, this top of the charts
has gone down to number five.
Now the most common question is
regarding jihad.
Muslims are fundamentalists. Muslims are
extremist. Muslims are terrorist. So
depending on how the media portrays
Islam, these common 20 most common
questions. The order may change, couple
may be added, some may be removed. So
every few years
it may change. But the common question
I'm normally the same wherever you go I
have traveled in different parts of the
world. Whether it be America, whether it
be UK, whether it be Singapore, whether
it be Europe, whether it be Saudi
Arabia, whether Pakistan, whether
Africa, whether Nigeria, whether Kenya,
these 20 common questions regarding
Islam among the non-Muslim is the same.
There may be an additional one or two
questions depending upon the society
like if you go in the western society
they may ask why does Islam not permit
the Muslim to take interest additional
but the 20 common questions are the same
there may be an additional one or two
questions depending upon the surrounding
depending upon the society but the 20
common questions remain the same so if
every Muslim memoriz izes the replies to
these 20 common questions which
quotation from Quran and Hadith which
quotation from the scriptures of the
non-Muslim whether it be the Bible
whether it be the Vedas whether it be
the upanishad whether it be Bhagwat Gita
then give the reply with reason and
logic
and fourthly with scientific evidence
inshallah
you'll be able to convince many
non-Muslims
in today's talk. We may not have time to
complete all
the replies to the 20 most common
questions but inshallah we'll try and
cover between 9 and 12 depending upon
the time that we have at our disposal
maybe 9 to 12 and the balance we'll
cover tomorrow in part two tomorrow's
talk would be misconceptions about Islam
part two the total
is about 3 hours the answers to all so
we'll will divide into two parts
inshallah. Today
after 9/11 the most common misconception
regarding Islam the most misunderstood
word in Islam today is jihad.
This word jihad is not only
misunderstood by the non-Muslims because
of the media even many Muslims they
misunderstand this word most of the
non-Muslims and many Muslims they think
that any war fought by any Muslim
whether it be for money whether it be
for wealth whether it be for power
whether it be for land whether it be for
language is called as jihad
Jihad does not mean any war fought by
any Muslim for any reason. Whether it be
for money, whether it be for wealth,
whether it be for power, whether it be
for language, whether it be for land.
Jihad comes from the Arabic word jihad,
which means to strive, which means to
struggle. So jihad basically means to
strive and struggle.
In Islamic context, jihad means to
strive and struggle against one's own
evil inclination.
Jihad means to strive and struggle to
make the society better.
Jiad also means
to strive and struggle against
oppression.
Jad also means to strive and struggle in
the battlefield in defense. So jad
basically means to strive and struggle.